♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HE FOOTAGE ON YOUR
SCREEN, THE PICTURE RIGHT THERE
WERE SHOP AT ONE OF OUR
PRODUCERS LAST WEEK.
WE WERE IN CALIFORNIA ALL WEEK
IN LOS ANGELES, SUPPOSEDLY ONE
OF THE RICHEST CITIES IN THE
WORLD AND IN SOME WAYS IT IS.
THE VIDEO YOU ARE WATCHING SHOWS
SOMETHING ELSE.
CALIFORNIANS POOR, TRASH FILLED
STREETS.
RIGHT IN DOWNTOWN, HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS IN THE SIDEWALKS AND
BLANKETING DOWNTOWN L.A.
THE FOOTAGE STARTS AT FIFTH
FREIGHT AND GOES WEST.
BLOCK AFTER BLOCK, TENT AFTER
TENTH.
THIS IS HOW THE POOR SPENT
EASTER SUNDAY AND CALIFORNIA.
THEY WEREN'T CLUSTERED ON ONE
SIDE OF THE ROAD, IT WAS LIKE A
SKID ROWS.
IT WAS LIKE MANY SKID ROWS.
HE CONTINUED.
IT IS AMERICA'S SECOND LARGEST
CITY.
THE CHEMIST BEGAN JUST TWO
BLOCKS AWAY FROM LITTLE TOKYO,
ONE OF THE MAJOR TOURIST
DESTINATIONS.
YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING, WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE PRICED OUT OF LOCAL
HOUSING, FEW PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY LIVING IN RVs, MILES
OF RVs PARKED ALONG THE
STREET.
THEY ARE INTENSE, WHY WOULDN'T
LOCAL LEADERS WANT TO SLOW OR
STOP THE FLOW OF NEW ARRIVALS TO
GET PRICES UNDER CONTROL?
TO OPEN UP NEW HOUSING?
THEY ARE DOING THE OPPOSITE.
L.A. IS A SANCTUARY CITY AND A
SANCTUARY STATE.
THEY WILL DENOUNCE OUR BORDERS
AND ATROCITY AND THAT IS AN
ABOMINATION.
THE POOR AND CALIFORNIA AREN'T
AFTERTHOUGHT, ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY ARE MULTIPLYING.
THAT'S WHY WHEN THE GOVERNOR
TRIED TO FIGHT IT, HE FLEW TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY TO DO IT WITH
EL SALVADOR.